welcome squid owes Joey here and I'm
happy to once again bring you all
another economics lesson now economics
has been mostly about the main
multiplayer modes so far like turf war
ranked etc but now that splat this is
over and we've all welcomed our new may
overlords I've got some time to actually
discuss one move the game that I haven't
really talked about much up until now
and that's salmon run now salmon run if
you guys haven't played yet it's the
four player co-op mode has a variety of
bosses that you need to team up and
fight against and there are actually a
lot of components in this mode much of
which require at least some kind of
nuance in order to succeed in it and so
what I'll be doing is showing you some
of the best practices and some of my
go-to ways to ensure success and to
eventually become a professional at this
mode and now if you haven't checked out
the first three ink anomic lessons which
I talk about movement weapons and gear
you should probably check those out
first because all all the tips I give in
there they apply to salmon run as well
and so if you have any other questions
or specific things that you want to
learn in splatoon too in general you
know feel free to leave them in the
comments below or ask me on Twitter I'm
at uncle fuzz and I'll try to get them
into the next video so quick rundown of
what salmon run is it's you and three
other squids you're given four random
weapons and the object is to protect
yourselves from the hordes of salmon is
and collect the eggs that they drop the
bosses that show up will drop three
golden eggs each and while each boss is
different there are a lot of small
details to get through but for the first
topic we're gonna be talking about
teamwork now the object of the game is
to really as more than any other mode I
feel is to work together there are four
of you here for a reason so anytime you
see a boss or anytime you see a
container that people aren't paying
attention to make sure you just press up
on the d-pad and tell them that it's
this way you always want to try and
stick together back each other up one
another one gets planted you know it may
be tempting to try and rush and deliver
as many eggs as possible on your own but
if you get caught in the middle of
nowhere and you gets planted and there's
no one else to help you out you're more
or less just kind of hurting your own
team so for example if you
the boss salmon it on your own make sure
to call it out so that other people can
come to you and you know you can take
all the eggs together the last thing you
want to do is abandon the golden eggs
and have them be stolen and brought back
into the water now one of the big
problems that you might run into is
actually the lack of coordination
especially for those of you who
freelance and play without voice chat so
what you wanna do is try as best you can
to organize the roles so if you see that
your team is mostly focusing on the
bosses and you know not as much on the
ads try to focus on them try to try take
out the little guys because they can be
a problem if left untouched and also if
you get splatted make sure to yell out
help so that your teammates can find you
they can revive you and then you can
keep going now and don't forget about
the obligatory Booya when you finish
around complete with the celebratory
teabag in motion okay so now that you
have your team set you want to make sure
that you familiarize yourself with the
weapons the game will give you four
random weapons every single session and
so the chances that you're gonna get
something that you are not that familiar
with that's not your favorite are pretty
high so what you want to do is make sure
you know the weaknesses and strengths of
each weapon that you get so something
like a charger can take out some bosses
in just a couple hits slashes are really
good for taking out multiple enemies
taking out crowds shooters and Dooley's
can mow down something like a stinger
really easily so if you're having
trouble with it maybe you know go visit
Sheldon and go into the training mode
and test out your weapons a little bit
to familiarize yourself also remember to
use your special weapons because each
person will get two per game and in the
chaos of everything going on all the
madness you might actually forget to use
it sometimes like that's happened to me
if you find yourself in a situation
where your game swarmed and a little bit
overwhelmed don't forget to use it but
also use it wisely each weapon is pretty
good at taking out in a different
assortment of enemies the stingrays
special can get far off bosses but it
can also cut through armor so something
like a drizzler or a scrapper can going
on really easily splash out you can use
it when you get swarmed you know it's a
pretty good way out the bomb launcher is
good when you have a Maz or a fly fish
around and you need
throw those bombs as quickly as possible
now the inkjet is a little bit more
situational as you'll most likely use it
to escape or try to get some long-range
attacks on some of the bosses and
speaking of bosses we're gonna be moving
on to the main topic here which is
knowing exactly what each boss Sammon it
does now there are quite a few of them
and each of them have a different
ability and there are guaranteed to
wreck your ink if you're not careful now
as you know you will have to complete a
tutorial in order to even play salmon
run so I'm not gonna go through exactly
what every single boss does because the
game kind of tells you that from the
beginning but I will give some tips
about what to prioritize because when
there are a bunch of different bosses on
the screen at once you really want to
find out which ones pose the biggest
threats bosses like the mozz or a
scrapper they're a little bit lower on
the priority level because they're
somewhat avoidable but don't ignore them
because they can still hurt you then the
steelhead drizzler and steel eel they
all require you to pretty much wait for
them to show their weak spot so you kind
of have to just wait around and that can
be a little bit trickier but if you have
a charger on your team let him take care
of it because they can take them down
from far away in just a couple of hits
and then there's the stinger and the fly
fish which are two of the most annoying
bosses in the game and they can wreak
havoc on your team from all the way
across the map so anytime you notice
them make sure that you zero in on them
if you're far away you can use your
stingray special to take either of them
out
but in general you just want to be
prepared for anything and everything
because after you've mastered the main
bosses the game will eventually throwing
trickier and trickier encounters like
you'll have nighttime battles you'll
have low tide battles on the beach
you'll have high tide encounters where
everything's kind of cramped into one
space you'll have cannons - man you'll
have fog everywhere there will also be
newer and harder bosses as well and I'm
gonna go through them right here and the
first one up is the griller and yep that
is a barbecue grill and so with the
griller does it targets and follows one
person and so the other three need to
shoot the fish that's hanging out the
back and so if you're the one targeted
you want to make sure you have a clear
path to get out of the way and also
don't lure it into your teammates
because that will cause a lot of
problems now one of the other bosses is
the Goldie and this guy will show up in
two different encounters one of them is
a rush which is basically a conga line
of salmon 'add and what they'll do is
they'll just target and follow a single
player somewhat similar to the griller
but during this you want to kind of
split up the work two Inklings that take
care of the rushing salmonids and the
other two that are shooting the Goldie
for the eggs and the other mode with the
Goldie's is the one with the gushers and
now this one's a lot tougher this one
will cause you some problems I'm sure
because what you'll have to do is you'll
have to open up each one of these valves
and find it most likely you'll need to
split up because it keeps moving around
you won't be able to say that this one
will always have the Goldie in it but
use the light inside of it as an
indicator you know the brighter it is
the closer you are to finding it and so
once it's out you want to chase it
around make sure you shoot it because
they'll keep continuously dropping eggs
grab them and bring them back to the
container and so the last special boss
is the mothership and what the
mothership does it launches Chinooks
basically these flying fish that are
holding these giant containers and
you'll only be able to get the golden
eggs while they're in the air so you
have to shoot them down with like a
charger or some longer ranged weapon but
once the Chinook's drop the Crais
regular salmonids will spawn and then
you'll have to deal with them now you
can't shoot the mothership in this phase
but periodically she'll come down and
try to suck the eggs out of the
container
and this is when you all have to gang up
on it and shoot it get rid of it stop it
from taking the eggs so keep an eye out
for these special waves mr. griswold
mention it right before it happens but
you always want to be prepared you
always want to make sure that you'll be
ready to take on anything and finally
for the last topic I know this may be
obvious but please don't forget to
collect your bonus
so just by simply plain salmon run
you're gonna earn points and every
hundred points that you earn will garner
you a bonus
and so bonuses actually make salmon run
a very very lucrative mode you'll be
able to get lots of money lots of
special gear lots of ability chunks you
know if you go on a good run you can
rack up those bonuses really quickly
really easily and it's actually one of
the easiest ways to get drink and meal
tickets for Krusty Shan so that you can
go and customize your gear like I know
that people are complaining that salmon
run isn't like a permanent thing like
it's only every couple days but once it
comes around you know you want to get in
there do as much as you can as much as
possible within 24 hours you know get
your money get your gear and get your
ability chunks squeeze it for all it's
worth while you can all right that's it
that should be all you need to know
about salmon run I hope this was helpful
for those struggling with the mode but
fellow professionals if you have any
tips that I didn't mention or if you
have any questions that I didn't cover
please leave them in the comments and
I'll try to answer them as best I can
you know if I don't get to them I'm sure
someone else very helpful will and as
always thanks to all you guys for
watching and supporting economics if you
enjoyed this lesson consider leaving a
thumbs up or even subscribing to the
GameSpot Channel I assure you there will
be more economics to come so stay tuned
for my future lessons and I will see you
squids next time
[Music]